how's it going bros my name is Pete I
get a lot of messages from you bros a
lot of them are really funny a lot of
them are really heartwarming and a lot
of them are really stupid one thing that
I noticed in a lot of messages that I
received from you bros when you open up
about your problems and things that's
happening seems to be a lack of
confidence so I wanted to dedicate
today's video in hopes to change that I
want you to feel confident about
yourself
so I listed five things that might help
with this it's not gonna be anything
original or innovative that you haven't
heard before but sometimes it's just
good to remind yourself
number one comparing yourself to others
is completely pointless you are your own
person with your own goals and your own
achievements so why would you compare
yourself to others it's completely
pointless don't do it if you have to do
it then compare yourself to someone that
you look up to someone that you can
aspire to be a better person someone
that makes you feel better by yourself
instead of worse it's so easy to look at
someone else's life and just think oh he
or she is so much better her life must
be perfect blah blah blah
let's get real here I don't care who you
are no one's life is perfect
everyone has problems the difference is
that we just don't post about them on
Facebook like we do with everything else
just remember that there's only one of
you that will only ever be one of you so
just let you be you number two is your
body image how you look at yourself I
get a lot of messages from you bro
saying you're not happy with who you are
how you look like if you're overweight I
don't know
and to be honest it's not something I
know how to help with because I don't
really struggle with it I feel content
with who I am and I want you to feel
this the same way by any means
I'm not flawless so it's not about that
it's just about being happy with who you
are people point out my flaws all the
time especially since I'm on the
Internet
things that I didn't even know was a
problem and until people told me like my
forehead is too big I have a giant mole
here which you might not be able to see
my nose is too white my my chin is too
what like long I haven't Leno chin not
muscular enough all these things people
tell me and maybe doesn't make me
happier but thing is [ __ ] what anyone
has to say about you and how you look no
one has a goddamn right to point out
anything about your appearance which
gives you every single right not to give
a [ __ ] what anyone else has to say about
it
number three is how you look at problems
or when bad things happen to you
everything happens for a reason I don't
believe that that would be stupid but
it's a really great way to look at
things and it helps you keep a positive
attitude when you're in a bad situation
which is really hard and I know a lot of
people seem to think of problems as this
just horrible thing that should never
happen and if anything bad happens your
life is over but really think of how
boring anyone would be if they never had
to deal with any kind of problem what
kind of boring person would that make
you problems help us grow it helps
become better people because we learn
from them just like mistakes but I also
want to remind you that it's totally
okay to be sad sometimes it's totally
okay to break apart a little bit being
happy all the time is just not realistic
and it's it might actually be a good
thing just remind you things will always
get better
number four is everything is gonna be
fine I don't care how bad of a situation
you're in or how much the world seems to
be against you you're not gonna be like
that forever and if you fight through it
wish I know you can it will be worth it
you just need time
everything's gonna be alright the final
note number five is a quote which I'm
sure you've heard many times before and
it's treat others treat others treat
others like you want to be treated
yourself it might seem weird how helping
others will make yourself feel better
but it's been scientifically proven that
it does and keeping a positive energy or
thought around others will keep clot
will keep out your own negative thoughts
now I'm not trying to be a guru of
thought or anything actually wrote a
book paradeen quotes like these but I'm
so it doesn't make any [ __ ] sense but
it's it's good to remind ourselves of
these things from time and time and I
just hope this video will help raising
your confidence a little bit because I
think confidence is key to so many
things and there's no reason for you not
to be just remember keep your chin up
be positive I'll always be here and
that's all for now stay awesome brush
you